you have success and you win games
accolades come along with it there's a
lot of guys who are deserving of those
accolades what we've seen with seven pro
bowlers and they'll be all pros in the
mix as well and it's it's uh it's
those are fun things again that's not
why you play the game you play the game
to dominate to compete and to win rings
but anyone who says that those
those things aren't on their mind are
not important to them
is not the type of competitor that i am
that stuff is important to me and i do
relish the opportunity to be in the mix
it means i'm playing well and our team
is in good position as well
[Music]
interesting thought there from aaron
rodgers that anyone who says mvps and
individual accolades don't matter in
football isn't the type of competitor he
is and maybe he's technically accurate
because he's the type of competitor who
is focusing on things that are unrelated
to the goals of football which are team
success and he tried to thread the
needle by saying if i'm getting the
individual accolades that means my team
is doing well it's kind of a clunky
argument to make and it could be as pete
demilitas has tried to goad us into
saying shade at tom brady whose position
is i don't care about that stuff all i
care about is winning championships look
at my rings
what do you think about this chris i i
think i think that was an mvp answer
from the mvp i mean damn they just he
said it like it is that was an awesome
answer you know he said i'm not i'm in
it to win rings and dominate and like
well that's what i want to do but i like
the other stuff just like every other
player in the history of football and
yeah whether they want to admit it or
not it's a real thing there's no doubt i
i love how rogers
embraces this part of all of it you know
instead of playing us like dummies and
being like i don't really care and i
don't pay attention to these things and
you know which is like when the guy says
that it means like he's going home and
getting online and going what is where
am i at today am i in the race am i
going to win
that's what those guys are doing
rogers is the kind of guy that's like
he's always paying attention to it and
paying attention to the league and
what's going on he really knows all the
little nuances in the league
and i
he he doesn't go home and then have to
stew about it he just goes wait i'm
going to go to practice tomorrow and
kick butt and we're going to kick butt
as a team and then i'm going to kick
butt individually and yeah he's
basically saying i want it all i want
the damn rings the mvp trophy and all of
it and so does everybody i i just give
them credit for laying it out there i
like that aspect of aaron rodgers i know
some people call it complaining or
making excuses and all that crap and
that's where i just i you know i defend
him as you can tell
and i agree with you that these guys who
are highly competitive
want it all they want all the praise
they want all the glory they want all
the recognition
the the difference for me
and i don't know that others out there
feel the same way i do but i know this i
could give two craps about
awards that are determined by human
beings because i understand there are
all sorts of factors that go into the
votes that are cast by human beings and
it's a flawed and imperfect process and
i don't really care i would rather be
judged by objective measures so lead the
league in passing yardage lead the
league in touchdowns lead the league in
wins go win the super bowl those are
objective indicators of success not
our 50 people enough of the 50 voters
are enough of them going to believe it's
me and not somebody else's kind of
warped quasi-popularity contest i don't
care frankly i i i don't care about that
kind of stuff i don't care about the
honor that that your fellow man may give
you i don't care about that
do your job do your job well and that
speaks for itself especially when you do
a job where it's all measured by how
many yards you throw versus how many
yards this guy throws so i i i just i
think that
i i just that's where i'm kind of having
a hard time with it because i really
don't think he should care about
anything
that reporters sports writers
broadcasters human beings vote on i
don't think anyone should care about
that stuff well that's my opinion no i i
get that you know i don't i don't think
he
it's like a make or break thing in his
life i think it's just about
yes he's an overall competitor and he
wants to win at everything i mean you
know i spent two two you know uh golf
holes with him out in lake tahoe two
summers ago i'm telling you he wanted to
whoop the crap out of the course and the
guys that were playing with them and he
wanted to impress me and go
he wanted me to walk away and go damn
that's the best golfer out here he had
an eagle and a birdie in the two holes i
walked with him not saying i'm a good
luck charm but i'm just saying all right
but either way i think that's just what
he is he is the ultimate showman he
wants to put on a show dominate be
talked about as the best you're right
the voting system's so flawed but the
fact that you're in the conversation
there is some justification to your play
a little bit to go okay well not all 50
guys are idiots that are voting you know
they're i must be doing something good
to be in that conversation and two it is
part of legacies like it or not it is
part of the conversation now and you're
right i agree with you totally that it's
a flawed popularity contest but at the
end of the day a lot of these guys
careers are measured on this this type
of thing and you know rogers i think you
know of course he's he's very aware of
his legacy and he lets that be known too
i think far more important to anyone's
legacy is winning a super bowl and being
super bowl atp not being the mvp of the
regular season and it's been now 21
years and counting since someone has won
both and it was kurt warner the last one
to be the league mvp and also win the
super bowl be the super bowl mvp so i i
just think that i agree isn't it funny
that
in adults
in athletes we admire this intense level
of competition that takes over
everything they do from playing gin
rummy to playing ping pong to playing
pinball to playing video games to
playing golf playing this playing that
this intense relentless competitive fire
we think is admirable when
those same traits that we see in a child
we think is
immature he's always got to win right oh
god can you give it a break johnny
you've got to win every game come on let
somebody else win it's just a weird
dichotomy that that we hold up adults
who are that way on a pedestal when we
look down on kids who just won't let it
go come on you don't have to win every
time do you and that's strange it is
strange but i don't know you're right
when you become a grown-up and money
becomes on the line and it becomes a
profession you know and it's a child's
game where you know no but they do it
about everything it's not a profession
like you said they do it about
everything drew brees is that way about
everything it becomes almost
right it becomes part of the legacy of
everything about them again i think it's
more about that it's the overall entity
and the aura around it you know
john elway i was growing up i would
always hear stories john elway kicking
people's butt on the golf you know the
golf course i think we've both heard the
story about how he used to kick
everybody's butt in um in pool right and
then one day uh this is a famous story i
was i've been told many times where a
teammate beat him and he was so
distraught about it that he sold the
damn pool table the next day and got a
new one
that's what psycho type a quarterbacks
do that are like hall of famers and that
kind of thing they are they want my dad
you know not that he's john elway or tom
brady but you know my dad did it in a
super bowl it was pretty big time he's
the same damn way i mean we could be
playing shuffleboard on you know
thanksgiving day and he's talking crap
and wants to let everybody know in the
room he's the best and going to kick
your butt that's just part of the
mindset of these guys and uh i just
think it's cool that rogers lets us see
it a little bit more
than some of the other players in
football
we're now at the point where we presume
that roger's going to win the award and
this was the whole purpose of the
segment as we have wasted it all talking
about roger's competitiveness
shireen williams made the point
yesterday is there a case to be made for
josh allen as mvp because patrick
mahomes isn't playing this weekend he's
not getting to 5 000 passing yards right
i think he's out i think it's over i
think it's rogers
but look at the difference here rogers
has 4059 passing yards and 44 passing
touchdowns josh allen has 43 20 42 total
touchdowns when you factor in rushing
and receiving doesn't he have one
receiving this year i think he has one
recipe i think he might be right yes he
does yes he does
and and uh uh so
um i i think it's closer than consuming
yeah yeah i hear you yeah this is a this
is a conflict for you what it is hey you
know and and josh allen i agree i mean
to what you're saying and shireen's
saying i mean first off they have the
same record the green bay packers do
right so we know that okay they're
they're playing at a high level yes
yards are better they don't have the run
game green bay has but just like all
those three on there alan has entered
the stratosphere of i can carry the team
and do things that the rest of you can't
other than maybe those three right there
nonetheless he has arrived and he's in
that type of conversation which is cool
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports